how good do we have it here in America
based on your experience all over the
world I mean this is a pure miracle
I think
I went to school at Columbia with the
generation
right and bring the Communist Revolution
into this country this is Colombia is
this is not Colombia yeah Colombia Pablo
Escobar this is Colombia University
Colombia let me pronounce it correct
Manhattan with our friend Gad said
basically was uh talking about the
wokism that's going so go ahead right so
I think this is what it shocks me
capitalize me so ethical so
compassionate that they they created the
term human rights I mean Columbus
Nursing we don't even know that that's a
concept like when I heard about animal
rights in South Korea I was like what do
you mean my puppy had rights I did not
know I had to write this is so much
human rights here that we got animal
rights that's pretty How You Like Me Now
yeah so
I don't know why I was doing with tear
down this ethical most amazing system
uses the word soft that we are so soft
yeah explain that go further on why you
think we are so soft here is because we
have it so good here
yeah I mean they complain of having too
much food like they complain about not
having actual problem they have to make
a problem out of nowhere like out of
like just literally thinner they created
Injustice like their Injustice like
there's a 10 000 pronouns and you cannot
pronounce them you cannot remember now
you're a bigot that's very interesting
what were the pronouns that you were
using in North Korea
I we we just had to read yeah there's
not even an eye you couldn't pick a he
she him they why we what it's just we
yummy that's really good the
revolutionaries that's a really good
question I don't why my brain went there
what what is their what is the policy on
homosexuality and you know but like what
I mean there's obviously gay people
there how does how does the Supreme
Leader and all them how do they how do
they do that are people trying I don't
have I have no idea what it's like over
there so I think that's where North
Korea is so different they denies love
between people they did not give us a
vocabulary so my mother never told me
that she loved me so we don't have the
word for love we don't have water for
human rights and we don't have the word
for gay
so that means you you cannot even know
what that is
somebody dancing you're like okay that
guy is not one of us like he's weird is
that what their mindset is yeah you're
not allowed to dance
you're not allowed to sing other than
the propaganda song oh my God you go to
prison if you move your body freely can
you imagine being a jail pet like what
are you in here for I moonwalked and now
I'm doing 20 and it's also you're not
allowed to make love to your wife
standing up because it could lead to
Dancing Yeah
when you talk about the labor camps what
is like an a day for someone that's in a
labor camp like what is it just wake up
eat and this all day till you're so
you're passing out what's what's what is
it because people people say that's like
one of the worst experiences so to be in
when you're sent to concentrating Camp
the first thing you cannot do is why am
I here
my question why yeah if you do you get
executed oh my gosh so they just it's a
three generation punishment so you don't
even know who messed up in your
traditions and family that I end up here
so you just show up to the prison camp
first thing you learn is you never ask
why you're there and you learn you never
look at the guard's eyes because you're
not human being anymore
you are the sub himo so you cannot look
at their eyes and they rape women
constantly they don't last more than
three months they let them clean those
nuclear debris oh my Nuclear debris and
they're getting raped and they they do
the biochemical testing on these inmates
like the Nazis did put in the gas
chamber and testing on this biochemical
weapons and you're saying so you're
saying so somebody in your three
generational family could have done
something way down you don't even know
what the hell and they just grab you and
they put you in yeah all I said a few
decades before and it came out now their
grandpa one day may be drinking with the
friends like in the 40s before anything
happened and one day maybe I'm not sure
social about communism and that came out
somebody later reported remember the
conversation in this 80s goes to police
and said I remember he said in the 40s
now you ended in the prison camp don't
you imagine that one more question
regarding
um capitalism communism if there's a
greater case example of communism versus
capitalism it is exactly what happened
in Korea versus North Korea and South
Korea if you look at South Korea
um who basically during the Korean War
align themselves with the USA in the 50s
and you know what is it the 38th
parallel and then North Korea aligned
themselves with the Soviet Union and
China and China yeah and if you look at
South Korea they are almost top 10 in
GDP in the world I think they're
numbered 10 or 11 right now yeah versus
you have North Korea they're not even on
the Spectrum so what have you
experienced just you've been to South
Korea so yeah I lived here you lived
there so the the the the benefits of
capitalism and democracy and everything
that kind of accompanies that in South
Korea versus the hellhole that is North
Korea there's no greater case example if
you would expound upon that yeah I think
that's it is nothing about your genetics
or your culture or and it or like
anything tradition it's all about
Freedom or of Communism tyranny right
when we let the individuals be free and
they innovate they create week worth and
we can achieve like Miracles and look at
North Korea the same exact potential we
create like living hell
so yummy can you go there's no way can
you when's the last time you visited
South Korea and is there like can you go
there and if you do go there what what
is that situation the intelligence don't
like me coming back because I'm on the
killing list of Kim Jong-un it's
embarrassing for them if I get assassin
in South Korea so wow and I'm pretty
sure they have people oh yeah just
waiting for somebody like you and what's
up what's the population of just Korea
as a whole so North Korea they don't
even know the population so many of them
dying of starvation so they say 24
million but more realistic or something
21 million the population hasn't grown
but South Korea now is 50 million people
almost okay so you're saying so what
what is that North you said about 30 21
and so you're the of the 290 here
congratulations here's what I want you
to do I want you to go visit South Korea
I've enjoy your time to spend one week
okay and then I want you to sneak into
North Korea I could do that and then I
mean report from there okay and you want
us to give us the differences I get 100
yeah okay your ticket is booked enjoy
this is a satellite map of Korea at
night look at North Korea oh my lights
it's just dark yeah
oh my God if does it if that isn't
capitalism Innovation Fremont Enterprise
I was watching I'm uh speaking at an
event last week in Vegas palau's event
and
the the Wonder speakers was a uh stress
speaker he's talking about there's good
stress there's bad stress you know all
this depression anxiety all this stuff
and I showed him a video I said I saw a
video from 50 Cent and it was the most
powerful point he made 50 Cent said
being depressed is a luxury
if you're depressed it's because you can
afford to be depressed he says go
explain it to the husband that's got
three kids working two jobs he doesn't
have any time to be depressed he's
working seven days a week any of these
guys that say they're depressed this is
50 Cent you can afford it it's a luxury
because if your back was against the
wall you would not have the luxury being
depressed it's a completely different
perspective so sometimes depression has
caused uh for people who have way way
too much time on their hands because
they're not being productive here you
are somebody that just came to America
who escaped gotten at an age that most
of us have a hard time letting our kids
be outside by themselves at that age let
alone escape a country as a girl
and find a way to come out here you know
you know the first speech you gave the
one that was publicized and it was how
many views did that thing get like 80
million views 70 million views almost a
billion once her first speech when her
story was told worldwide of where was
that at that first speech Island in
Ireland one billion views I don't know
if you've seen this or not when she's
younger telling the story super she's
shaking talking emotional obviously at
this point this is how many years since
that speech how many years ago was it
when you give that eight years eight
years from giving that speech to where
she's at today the the the this is it
yeah this was it when this message was
given eight years ago to where she's at
right now oh yeah one young world oh my
yeah pause the audio there you go yeah
the audio is the one that we don't want
to hear if you can't just go to see what
she looked like as a when she's telling
the story uh uh right there that's her
telling the story a billion views later
right there wow you only Park to now
hear coming out with her book her second
book to share the story of what happened
on how more Americans can become
grateful and realize how lucky you are
to be living in the greatest country in
the world so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]